hi
I'm
now going to take some cream
and mix it into the bowl
and then lick
the spoon oh
hello I'm Hugh Grant
and I'm Josh Hartnett
and this is First Impressions from the
lad Bible is that is that you I thought
you were going to jump back in there
[Music]
oh come on Hermione let's go and play
Quidditch
oh my God It's gotta be um the Twilight
of course
Harry Potter thank you
he deserved it and I'm gonna eat his
children
do it again
you deserved everything he got and I'm
gonna eat his children
I would need his children oh fight his
ear off
oh Mike Tyson yeah really good
yeah I think Define love because I
my marriage my original marriage was you
know terrific but I think for my mother
especially now in Haddam and Jubilee
year I think
okay I got it now Prince Charles my bit
um
you were already supposed to blow the
bloody doors Michael Kane marvelous yes
oh god
um
uh uh uh uh
come on
yeah okay
okay uh I'm gonna say uh you know when a
guy plays this guy yeah he's got his uh
Spanish accent he's got a Hispanic the
South American accent and he's always
his nose is blocked up
um wait a minute what else does he make
black quick
Spanish right he's also uh Italian maybe
yeah yeah but he's Italian and he's uh
it's got to be Scarface it's got to be
opportunity thank you you threw me off
with the Spanish I was going to say yeah
I know I couldn't think of a single film
above his girlfriends he'd been in
[Music]
this game has gone on long enough
me is that Gollum
no Gollum
uh
the Force is with you oh him I've never
seen a Star Wars film
um oh Jesus seriously what's it called
the little fella
I'm the little fella it is the little
fella yeah the Little Feather install
Yoda Yoda yes yes
impossible
well
okay I'll try it
and I I miss hi
I'm
now going to take some cream
and mix it into the bowl
and then lick
the spoon Nigella lost it very good
oh that was really really good it was
more huge chests than I expected to see
today
Frankenstein
well
Frankenstein's monster
well okay
it's very it's so good it's it's tragedy
not to get it
oh you've dug yourself up you're the
undead
but you're not that's another word for
the undead
but the vampire I hear people laughing
at us in the other room a vampire a
zombie hey oh I'm good at these
[Laughter]
laughs
I see you I see you Nana ah I'm cleverer
than that
well done
it would have gone a little higher
pitched with you do you think
oh I would have got that right away
yeah well done well done you both did
amazingly well yeah it was yes
[Music]
I just know that it is a cooking show